hi I'm Yuna and I'm here to cover what's
new a material design on the web we've
got a lot to go over so let's get
started the first update is the material
theme builder tool on glitch the tool
itself is a self-contained application
that showcases each of the material
components with prompts to update the
base theme shown it helps teams to
leverage the three subsystems of theming
within material typography shape and
color the tool uses SAS variables to
show users how to adjust an interface
style and make their own brands shine by
changing just a few lines of code within
a theme file for example color can be
adjusted via a series of variables such
as primary secondary background and
surface colors these compared with on
colors which represent the text color on
top of a variable background shape
customization can be made for three
component size classes small medium and
large components small components
include buttons and input medium
components include modal's and dialogs
and large components include menus and
drawers there's a great shape tool on
material diode to help you visualize
these changes on our components before
applying them to your codebase and
finally we can adjust typography through
the generalized MVC typography variable
or through SAS maps that allow you to
customize individual typographic levels
such as having a separate weight and
font family for primary headlines rather
than the body copy in the end your theme
could look something like this this is
just one example that comes from Google
developer days in China we've made
thousands of themes around the world so
far so head over ticklish to add your
own we're also working on a set of
guidelines for adapting dark themes
using material components for example
and a dark theme Google materials color
palette reduces intensity to mitigate
visual vibration or strong color
contrast against a darker background
instead of solely adding drop shadows to
illustrate elevation and depth and a
dark theme a lighter overlay is applied
check out the material to i/o guidelines
for more design guidance on how to
transition your designs
into a dark theme considering contrast
depth desaturation and limiting colors
for accessibility to help with this
transition MDC web has released a set of
typography theme variables that respond
to background shades for text styles you
can now also use the theme variables in
three different ways the most supported
and robust technique is with our SAS
styling API using variables and mix-ins
to override styles you can also create
CSS classes with the variable names to
style them by and finally for modern
browsers CSS custom properties can be
used for the theme styling we're still
working on full support for custom
properties at this time we provide so
many options because theming should not
be limiting you can extend the theme
builder to make your own theme as unique
as your product leverage our code and
build on top of our material components
to quickly and easily get started
building product on the web the next new
feature and material is data tables you
asked
we listened our designers consider these
three principles when it comes to data
tables the first is that data must be
organized in a meaningful way data
tables should also be allowed for user
interaction and finally those
interactions should be as logical as the
structure of the data table itself data
tables come with some basic default
functionality such as row selection but
you can also hook them up to other
components such as these filter chips
check out the links provided below for a
deep dive into how you can actually
implement data tables in your web
projects and combine material components
for orchestrated actions we also have a
new density subsystem option in material
material design uses low-density space
by defaults with large tap targets and
margins but offers high density space
when it improves the user experience
we brought density into our system for
the following reasons the first is for
scan ability scan ability is improved
for data heavy applications with a
higher density interface the second is
that dense UIs may actually help users
focus by reducing space between act
and finally more content is available to
the user on a single screen in more
high-density applications whether or not
to increase your us density can be
determined by how users interact with a
component components with high density
enable users to process and take action
against large amounts of information in
a more manageable way lists tables and
long forms are components that benefit
from increased density but density
shouldn't be used for every component
for example don't apply density to
components that involve focused tasks or
alert the user of changes such as snack
bars or dialogues applying high density
to alerts reduces their ability to
command attention a series of new
styling classes on the web allows for us
to access density in three ways the
default component size a comfortable
size which provides a higher density
display while respecting minimum touch
target size and compact which may be
used for pages with a lot of information
but may be inappropriate for user
actions materials at i/o got an update
as well we now provide a cross-platform
view of all of our component offerings
on a dedicated components page this page
allows for quick access to components an
overview of cross platform availability
should make it easier to navigate our
product and implement it for your needs
check out material do slash components
to browse them all yourself and finally
we're kicking off a new initiative this
year to focus on supporting material
across web frameworks why we know that
most of you are developing web apps
using a framework and the open source
community has stepped up immensely both
in components for some of the most
adopted web frameworks out there we want
to celebrate this work and help bring
the material design vision to life
along with our open source community so
many of you have already built your own
wrapper libraries using MVC webs
components foundations and adapters and
we're working more closely with the rest
of the open source community as well
we've updated material to IO to link to
three of the most popular open source
component libraries they've already
uncovered bugs in the material design
guidelines and asked great questions
helping us to make material even better
and we're helping them to follow the
spec and the material guidelines more
closely as well we look forward to
continuing the conversation and working
to bring the material design vision to
every platform and framework making it
easier for everyone to use material
design on the web there's so much to
explore and play with from theming to
density to data tables to new website
features and our open source community
it's an exciting time to be building
with material so check out material dot
IO and the links below where you can
find all the resources that I mentioned
today can't wait to see what you build
material I'll see you on the web
[Music]